تعلمون أن الناس ما زالوا في حيرة شديدة
من عدم جاهزية
المخابرات والأمن أه أجهزة
إسرائيل فما أنا ما أتساءل هل هذه
حالة مبالغة في تقدير
الخدمات الإسرائيلية أم أن إسرائيل قللت من
حماس أعتقد أن الأخيرة إسرائيل أه تحمل
حماس  في نظر سيئ إلى حد ما،
فهذه مفاجأة تكتيكية وليست
مفاجأة استراتيجية، ضع في اعتبارك أن إسرائيل
لديها استراتيجية تسمى قص العشب
مما يعني أن الحروب العادية أو الصغيرة
ضد حماس كانت سبع حروب منذ عام
200 و8، لذا فهي مجرد مسألة
قبل أن يكون هناك هجوم آخر، لكنها
مفاجأة تكتيكية من حيث
حجم الهجوم وتوقيته
الذي صدم
الإسرائيليين بوضوح إلى متى يمكن لحماس أن تستمر في هذا الأمر،
الآن كما تعلمون أن رئيس الوزراء الإسرائيلي
قد أعلن بشكل أساسي  الحرب على
حماس ليس بشكل أساسي ولكنه أعلن
الحرب على حماس وخاصة في حالة حدوث
هجوم بري إسرائيلي محتمل، فهل هم
مستعدون لمواجهة
ذلك؟ لذلك أعتقد أن حماس كانت
تطارد أمرين هنا،
الأول هو أن حماس  يريد أن
يعامل إذا أردت
كدولة عادية ويريد الجلوس
والتحدث عن السلام مع الإسرائيليين ولكن هذا
يعني التوصل إلى حل وسط على كلا الجانبين،
ولم يكن الإسرائيليون على
استعداد أبدًا للتوصل إلى حل وسط قبل أن أعتقد
ذلك  لقد نظرت حماس إلى الوراء 50 عامًا،
وتذكر أن هذه هي
الذكرى السنوية الخمسين لحرب يوم كيبو حيث
بدأ المصريون حربًا لمجرد
جلب الإسرائيليين إلى
طاولة المفاوضات وأعتقد أن هذه
الحرب بالذات قد تكون مماثلة ولكن ذلك
ويتدفق إلى الجزء الثاني هو أنه
ربما يكون الجزء الأول من الحرب قد
انتهى الآن، حيث أرادت حماس هؤلاء
الرهائن ولديها المئات منهم،
وبالتالي فإن الإسرائيليين الذين يشنون
هجومًا بريًا على غزة كما
يتحدثون عنه سيكون أمرًا صعبًا للغاية.
صعب لذلك أعتقد أن الرهائن
جزء من هذا أيضًا وأعتقد أن
المسار المستقبلي للحرب يعتمد على
هؤلاء الرهائن، ويعتمد على هؤلاء
الرهائن لأنك تعتقد أنه سيتم
استخدامهم
كدروع بشرية إلى حد كبير، كما
فعل الإسرائيليون  السيطرة الكاملة على
غزة، يمكنهم إسقاط القنابل في أي مكان
وقتل أي شخص، الشيء الوحيد الذي
يمنعهم سيكون قلقًا بشأنهم أيضًا
قتل الرهائن
أم ماذا تعزو
لقدرات حماس المحسنة التي سمحت
لهم بتنفيذ عملية بهذا
الحجم؟  القصة القديمة أن أه
الناس في كل مكان أذكياء للغاية وكان
الإسرائيليون يعلمونهم كما قلت كان هناك
حوالي سبع حروب كبيرة
وصغيرة منذ عام
200 و8 لذلك فقد وجدت حماس الآن
طريقة من خلال الإستراتيجية الإسرائيلية
إحدى النتائج  في هذه الحرب سيكون على
إسرائيل تغييرها
أه قص استراتيجية العشب والتوصل
إلى شيء جديد